i'm brent koff to our viewers on pbs in
the united states and to all of you
around the world
welcome tonight the u.s capitol is on
high alert
security has been ramped up in
washington d.c after intelligence
officials warned that a right-wing
militia may be preparing
an attack on the capitol building the
fbi warning that
far-right conspiracy theorists have made
plans to storm the legislative building
in an attempt to return former president
donald trump
to power although police say the plans
lack
credibility the house of representatives
canceled all sessions planned for it
today
as a precaution the capitol complex has
been on high alert for two months now
following the january 6th riots that
left
five people dead all right let's go to
our correspondent now oliver salad he is
in washington d.c good evening to you
oliver can you tell us i mean what's the
situation at the capitol building right
now do we know
well the capital really looks like a
fortress right now so
there's this giant fence that's
surrounding the whole capital area so
you can't get anywhere
near the premises there's razor wire on
top and quite frankly it really looks
almost impossible
to climb that fence also there's some 5
000 soldiers deployed
waiting on the other side of that fence
that were carried there this morning so
i was just there
and looked at the situation myself
really
more police and journalists than anyone
else on the streets
near the capitol area and it really
shows there's a tense atmosphere right
now
and that rumors are enough to put police
on high alert
right now in this situation there's a
lot of fear that the scenarios in the
insurrection of january could be
repeated and therefore capitol police
just today
requested that the national guard would
stay another additional two months
earlier the speaker of the house nancy
pelosi delivered a press conference
let's listen what she had to say
we have to have what we need when we
need it and in the
numbers of that we need it but that's a
security decision
we have to ensure with our security
uh that we are safe enough
to do our job but not impeding
i mean i live in san francisco so people
said well if you want to be totally
protected
by from earthquakes you just live in a
like a an iron igloo
and then you're completely safe well who
wants to do that
yeah oliver we understand that capitol
police they have requested
that the national guard continue to
provide security there at the capitol
building for another
two months what does that tell us then
about
the risk factor here the the worry that
another trump militia will try to attack
again
well the threat is very real brent and
the fbi director christopher wray just
very recently confirmed that at a senate
hearing there's a sufficient
intelligence
to back that so a lot of chatter on
social media that was evaluated
where an undisclosed militia was
apparently planning an attack
for this day but there's also on the
other hand this political will to not
let this
insurrection happen again so the
security
was tightened around the capital in
recent days the big difference really
if you want to compare to the january
6th
events is that law enforcement is
prepared right now and it looks very
safe
that area the problem of course is
another one and that is congress
currently has to be protected by five
thousand soldiers and a fence
with razor wire on top and the question
is of course how long is such a
situation really tenable
in oliver maybe you could explain to us
why today why is march
4th significant for those
trump supporters who believe in
conspiracy theories
we have to go back in history a little
bit march the fourth was the
inauguration day until 1993
and it uh to understand why is it is
still relevant
for a q a on this conspiracy theory you
have to dig into that theory
that a lot of militia groups buy into by
the way
therefore they believe the us government
was turned into a
corporation after uh march the fourth
1933 and that franklin roosevelt was the
last
real president as they believe of the
united states and according to q
anon donald trump is the only legitimate
president after uh that date and he
will according to that theory be
inaugurated today
so we will see how that plays out okay
well there's still
some hours left to go in this day
we'll see what happens oliver salad on
the story for us in washington thank you
oliver
you